All the things we know of the properties of the cancer cell could be traced to
the malfunction of genes.
That,
in turn,
has raised the possibility of very,
very precise therapeutics,
because if you can identify the malfunctioning genes in any individual
tumor,
you can,
in principle,
devise a therapeutic that
specifically targets that malfunction.
And we call this targeted therapy.
Actually the very first example was in breast cancer many years ago,
when it was discovered that the estrogen receptor,
the molecule that the hormone estrogen binds to,
and that leads to the effect of estrogen on breast tissue,
that if you inhibited that, you would have a favorable
effect on many breast cancers.
And it turned out that these breast cancers were expressing the estrogen receptor.
Those that didn't express the estrogen receptor did not respond to
the therapeutic.
So that's a thirty year old version of
targeted therapy. Flash forward to our
current knowledge about the malfunctioning genes of cancer cells,
the next triumph was with a relatively rare disease, known as
chronic myeloid leukemia.
This was an inevitably fatal disease.
The standard chemotherapeutics had marginal
utility with the disease,
and we knew that there was a particular malfunctioning
gene in those leukemia cells. And
working with a drug company,
a young medical scientist named Brian Druker
demonstrated that an existing therapeutic that was on the shelf, not being
used, was effective against that
malfunctioning gene that was common to all chronic
myeloid leukemia. And the very first tests
of that therapeutic with patients with chronic myeloid leukemia,
had what I would call a Lazarus effect.
I mean,
patients were on their deathbed and literally stood up within days of getting
this therapeutic and walked out of the hospital.
It was astonishing.
And we have other examples now.
What we need is a complete catalogue of
those genetic malfunctions in various kinds of cancer that are common
enough to create therapeutics that can then be ready to go
for any individual patient.
We need the ability for every hospital to test every
individual tumor for all the genetic malformations, malfunctions,
for which we have therapeutics,
and we're rapidly approaching that capability.
The information in our genes is encoded by an
alphabet of four molecules called
nucleotides,
and it's a simple alphabet,
the order in which the letters are arranged encode
all the functions of a cell. The first time that that order
was determined,
it cost a huge amount of money and took a long time to do--
years.
Now it can be done in a day, for less than a thousand dollars.
We call this complete genome sequencing.
The genome is a term that simply refers to the entire genetic
information contained in a cell.
Right now,
most advanced cancer
centers will either
determine the complete sequence of that alphabet
in the genome of a patient's cancer cell.
You compare that to the genome from their normal cells,
and you can spot any genetic malformation that gives rise
to a malfunction.
So you get a read out of potential targets
for therapeutics.
This is a work in progress.
And the biggest impediment to a completion of
the project is data analysis.
The data are accumulating more rapidly than the bioinformaticists can decipher it.
What's the catch here?
The catch here is a very old and daunting
enemy,
and that's called drug resistance.
Sooner or later,
even with an exquisitely targeted therapy,
such as the one I described for chronic myeloid leukemia,
the original drug is called Gleevec,
and it was truly a miracle drug,
sooner or later,
the tumors develop resistance.
The first therapeutic works for a while,
and then you have to have another one, that works for a while,
and you have to have the another one.
Now,
why is this happening?
The reason this is happening is something that we did not appreciate until very
recently.
And that is,
if you take a large tumor that's got trillions of
cells in it,
and you look at the individual cells,
which we can now do, if you look at them one by one
for the order of the alphabet in their genome,
I think it's safe to say that no two cells in a tumor are
exactly alike,
genetically.
The differences may be very small,
but they're not exactly alike.
That means that there are a trillion possibilities for
a particular form of drug resistance to be lurking in
the mass of a tumor.
So you kill off 99.9% of the cells and what's left?
That rare cell in which the resistance to the drug has
already developed, simply by genetic accident.
It's simple,
just random genetic variation, which creates this
incredible, what we call heterogeneity, tumor heterogeneity.
This is only recently appreciated and it is a daunting challenge.
And we don't quite know how to deal with it yet.
How do we deal with tumor heterogeneity?
Because until then,
we are going to have this relentless treadmill.
And one approach,
of course,
is a time honored mechanism,
what we call combination therapy.
So some tumors have been cured with conventional chemotherapy
by combining several drugs at one time.
We think we know how that works,
but we also know it doesn't always work,
and sooner or later,
the patients who have responded even to combination therapy, die of their
disease.
To me,
that's the great present challenge.
How do we deal with this extraordinary heterogeneity?
That brings onto the scene immunotherapy.
Immunotherapy is different because it's not
a chemical like chemotherapy or like targeted
therapy that we talked about. Immunotherapy utilizes either immune
cells or the antibodies made by immune cells
to either unleash the immune
system to kill tumor cells,
well by one means or another, unleashes the immune system to kill tumor cells.
Well,
there's nothing new under the sun after a fashion.
This works in some people and not in others,
and it works for a while,
and with a few exceptions,
ultimately it fails because of resistance.
And the resistance is distinctive from the kind that
occurs for targeted pharmacological
therapy,
but it is again of a sort that
can arise spontaneously in that lonely
cell amongst the trillion of a tumor.
It appears that some people,
some tumors,
have this in advance of receiving immunotherapy.
Others,
it appears later,
after you've killed off much of the tumors.
Now,
can we combine immunotherapy with the pharmacological targeted therapy?
Absolutely,
it's just, this is all very recent.
So this is just now underway and how effective it will be
remains to be seen.
You're coming at the tumor in two very different ways,
and that's good.
How efficacious it will be remains to be seen, it's too early to know.